we end up listening to what everybody
else has to say we may forget to do what
we are inspired so listen everybody's
gonna have an opinion on what you should
do with your life everybody so
throughout this journey I have learned
to block everything out and focus on my
truth rise and shine it's an espresso
time what's that belief nation it's evan
i believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right to get there grab your coffee
and sip on today's message ignore the
noise over to you go or Gopal das also
if you want to know a group all das and
how their successful entrepreneurs have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence to link to join is in
the description below
it's easy to make a buck very hard to
make a difference a vegetable vendor
used a whiteboard with the words fresh
vegetables sold here to attract people
to buy his vegetables a man came up to
him and said simply by seeing we can
tell that your vegetables are so fresh
why do you need to advertise them as
fresh crop off the word fresh the vendor
did so leaving behind the words
vegetables sold here on the board
another man came up and said we know
you're selling vegetables not fruits why
don't you wipe out the word vegetables
the vendor complied left on the board
now with two words sold
after a while an elderly lady approached
them and said if you're sitting in the
market you're not giving your veggies
for free I'll take off that sole the
vendor removed the sole and the
whiteboard had only one word left here a
schoolboy passing by teased the
vegetable seller saying everyone in the
world knows you're sitting here not
there why the here the vegetable seller
I raised the last word making the
whiteboard clean and empty another
person came up and said only a stupid
man would keep such a nice whiteboard
empty why don't you write something on
it to advertise your vegetables
everybody around us has an opinion to
make everybody around us has a
suggestion to offer and most often with
the best intentions but if we end up
listening to what everybody else has to
say we may forget to do or - we are
inspired what we are meant to do in the
noise of others suggestions and opinions
don't lose your voice take good advice
but also learn the art of navigating
through that advice to follow your own
journey so listen everybody's gonna have
an opinion on what you should do with
your life everybody your your friends
your family your culture your society
your community your customers online
haters everybody's got an opinion on
what you should do with your life and
it's tempting to want to take the advice
one because it gives us advice but - it
is also somebody to blame right like if
it doesn't work out it's not my fault is
that person's fault they said I should
do it at some point though you have to
decide that you are gonna be an adult
that you are in control that you want to
go off and build your own life and you
only you know what that looks like and
you have to have the courage to the
confidence to step up and say I'm in
charge this is my life now I get to
decide what I want to do and some
opinions will matter and some opinions
will make a difference and others you
have to let bounce off you you're not
gonna be able to please everybody
everybody has it
you know what you should do with your
life and the only one that really
matters truly is this one right here so
how do you decide how do you know what
the difference is how do you know which
opinions you should take which you
should listen to because on the one hand
it's you want to take advice you want to
take counsel you don't know everything
and on the other hand it's it's your
life you got to decide how do you make
those two things work together I'm gonna
give you three ideas that I think could
really help you number one is understand
what your one word is your one word is
the most important core Bob mine is
believe yours is whatever it is it's
worth going through the exercise I think
is one of the most important exercises
you can ever do in your life it becomes
a filter through which you see the world
and so for me it's belief and believe is
around believing in yourself having
self-confidence believing in the work
that you're doing having passion for it
and believing that it's gonna work out
believe it in the impact believing that
there is light at the end of the tunnel
even if you only see darkness around you
right now
that's belief and so all of the
decisions that I make are through the
lens of believe every new piece of
content and I put on my channel is
through the lens of belief and so if you
give me advice that has nothing to do
with believe it may be great potential
advice but it's not for me how do I know
it's for me because I'm standing on my
rock of belief and if you don't know
what value you stand on it's easy to get
pulled in a lot of different directions
it's easy to look at somebody else's
life and say I want to be like that no I
want to be like that no oh maybe you're
right I should go over here you don't
have confidence because you don't know
who you are and so the starting point is
figuring out what your one word is
because that is at the core it's your
most important core value so someone
might say for my youtube channel hey you
should profile the top two stupidest
mistakes that this person's made or the
top most hateful things that that person
said you know are the top reasons why
this person is an idiot
chances are those reasons would actually
blow up you know people like negativity
more than positivity unfortunately I'm
not gonna make those videos it's not
believed right I want to spread
positivity and hope and optimism that's
what I want to spread in the content
that I put out and so it's an easy no
even though from a strategy point of
view it might be a great thing to blow
up my channel I don't want to go down
that path it's not believed and so when
you understand what your one word most
important core value is it becomes a
filter for your entire
your entire business and as questions
and feedback and suggestions come into
you it becomes that filter so you can
make better decisions
step number two is a boom boom boom boom
test and what I mean by that is if your
heart is going boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom like you're nervous
somebody suggest something to you and it
sounds exciting but you're nervous and
you're scared then you have to go and do
that thing you have to go and do that
thing just to teach yourself that you
were the kind of person who when you're
nervous when you're scared when you're
fearful you jump into it you attack it
you want to beat it because if you want
to go out and do some crazy big thing
right we're entrepreneurs we've got a
big crazy mission that we're trying to
go off and save the world from self aim
right we want to spread our message if
you can't do this one little scary thing
in front of you you can't do that you
know where you're gonna go off and
accomplish that big thing and so train
yourself anytime your heart is being
nervous right as boom when you're scared
of doing something you're called upon
you're asked to rise to a challenge
you're nervous you're fearful you're
scared go and do that thing just to show
yourself that you can that's how you
actually build self-respect that's how
you actually build self-confidence it's
when you're feeling afraid and you jump
in and do it anyway I don't believe in
be fearless I don't think you can be
fearless I think if you're fearless on a
daily basis it means you're playing life
so small that nothing scares you
I think it's feeling the fear and doing
it anyway it's feeling the fear insane
I'm scared of this and I'm the kind of
person who rises to a challenge and I'm
gonna go off and attack it and so when
you get a suggestion when somebody gives
you an opinion is this something that
you actually want to do is this
something that makes you scared and if
yes then you have to go off and do that
thing just to show yourself that you can
and the third filter is what will you
regret if you get hit with a suggestion
somebody says you should do this think
about will you regret not doing it we
very rarely regret the things that we do
we regret the things that we didn't do
we regret the actions not take it and so
when you get hit with a suggestion and
you want to do it but you're afraid and
we got the boom boom boom test already
imagine your life at 100 years old
fast forward you're at the end of your
life you're sitting on your rocking
chair you're you're in some retirement
home life is almost over for you
look back in the past decades of your
life will you regret not having taken a
key on this is the thing I use to help
push me through fear as well if somebody
suggests hey you should go do an
interview with this person and I'm
afraid means I have to do it but also I
fast forward to 100 years old and said I
could have done that you know I could
have done that I could have made that
thing happen but I didn't and I've lived
the past 40 50 60 70 80 years depending
on how old you are with regret and so I
imagined it as I thought you know
something stuck in my tooth something
stuck in my tooth I can't get it out and
it's bothering me but then I punch
myself in the arm on how that hurt I
punched hard I punch myself in the arm
and so I don't feel the toothache
anymore I don't feel that thing second
me to my teeth that's what we're Brett
can't be used for you don't want to live
in regret 24/7 you'd want to live in the
negativity and the fear 24/7 but in
moments when you feel like you're about
to play small in moments when you can
hit with this opinion or suggestion that
you know is the right thing for you but
you're afraid that it's not going to
work out I use that fear of regret to
make it so big in the moment that I have
to go off and do that thing that's what
helped me get my youtube channel going
that's what helped me do my
presentations and my tours and my
speaking gigs and my books and all of
these things I'm scared I'm afraid to do
it I imagine myself at a hundred and say
if I don't write that book if I don't
make those youtube videos if I don't go
and interview that person if I don't try
to push my 10 million subscriber goal if
I don't do it I'm going to regret it for
the rest of my life and that fear forces
me into positive action that go off and
do it now got a really special bonus
gift that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what filter are you gonna use to
make your decisions better so the next
time somebody gives you feedback and
you're thinking about it what filter
you're gonna use to help you make the
best decision from the three that I gave
I love to hear your feedback put in the
comments below
let me tell you
you should feel so proud of making it to
this day
and I hope that you're excited to get
started on that next chapter but I also
imagine that you might think about all
of that history all those heroes who
came before you and you might also feel
a little pressure you know pressure to
live up to the legacy of those who came
before you pressure to meet the
expectations of others and believe me I
understand that kind of pressure I've
experienced a little bit of it myself
UC graduates I didn't start out as the
fully firm formed first lady who stands
before you today no no I had my share of
bumps along the way back when my husband
first started campaigning for president
folks had all sorts of questions of me
what kind of first lady would I be what
kinds of issues would I take on would I
be more like Laura Bush or Hillary
Clinton or Nancy Reagan and the truth is
those same questions would have been
posed to any candidate spouse that's
just the way the process works but as
potentially the first African American
first lady I was also the focus of
another set of questions and
speculations conversations sometimes
rooted in the fears and misperceptions
of others was I too loud or too angry or
too emasculating or was I too soft too
much of a mom not enough of a career
woman then there was the first time I
was on a magazine cover it was a cartoon
drawing of me with a huge afro and a
machine gun now yeah was satire but if
I'm really being honest that knocked me
back a bit it made me wonder well just
how are people seeing me or you might
remember the onstage celebratory fist
bump between me and my husband after
primary when that was referred to as a
terrorist fist jab and over the years
folks have used plenty of interesting
words to describe me one said I exhibit
exhibited a little bit of uppity ISM
another noted that I was one of my
husband's cronies of color cable news
charmingly referred to me as Obama's
baby mama
and of course Barack has endured his
fair share of the insults and slights
even today there are still folks
questioning his citizenship and all of
this used to really get to me back in
those days I had a lot of sleepless
nights worrying about what people
thought of me wondering if I might be
hurting my husband's chances of winning
his election
fearing how my girls would feel that
they found out what some people were
saying about their mom but eventually I
realized that if I wanted to keep my
sanity and not let others define me
there was only one thing I could do and
that was to have faith in God's plan for
me
I have to ignore all of the noise and be
true to myself and the rest would work
itself out so throughout this journey I
have learned to block everything out and
focus on my truth and you want more
google pal da stuck at the 5
life-changing pieces advice from him I
think you'll enjoy the videos right
there next to me continue to believe and
I'll see you there isn't it amazing how
many plans we make and isn't it a
reality not everything goes according to
our plans
[Music]